well you mentioned uh because I talked
to Mark about faith and God and you said
you were impressed by that
um what's your own belief in God and how
does that affect your work
you know
I never really considered when I was
younger I guess my parents were atheist
so I was right it's kind of atheist and
I never really considered how absolutely
like silly atheism is because like
I create worlds right every like game
creator like how are you an atheist bro
if you create worlds together but no one
created the art world man that's
different have you heard about like the
big bang and stuff yeah I mean what's
the Skyrim myth origin story in Skyrim
I'm sure there's like some part of it in
Skyrim but it's not like if you ask the
creators like the the big bang is in
Universe right I'm sure they have some
big bang notion in Skyrim right but that
obviously is not at all how Skyrim was
actually created and it was created by a
bunch of programmers in a room right so
like you know it just it struck me one
day how just silly atheism is right like
of course we were created by God it's
the most obvious thing
yeah that's uh
that's such a nice way to put it like
we're we're such powerful creators
ourselves
it uh it's silly not to conceive that
there's creators even more powerful than
us yeah
ocean gives me a lot of
Chicago what it gives a lot of religious
people it's kind of like it just gives
me Comfort it's like you know what if we
mess it all up and we die out
yeah and it's in the same way that a
video game kind of has comfort in it God
will try again
or there's balance like somebody figured
out a balanced
view of it like how to like so it's it
all makes sense in the end
like uh a video game is usually not
gonna have crazy crazy stuff you know
people will come up with uh like uh
well yeah but like man who created God
like that's God's problem no like I'm
not gonna think this is this is what you
ask me what if God I'm just living God
I'm just this NPC living in this game I
mean to be fair like if God didn't
believe in God he'd be as you know silly
as the atheists here